all right people I wanted to chime in on
this brouhaha between Hillary Clinton
and Tulsi Gabbard because I've had Tulsi
Gabbard in this very studio in my garage
right here and as you probably heard
Hillary Clinton basically called Tulsi
Gabbard who is a congresswoman a sitting
congresswoman a democratic congresswoman
from Hawaii she basically called her a
Russian asset and if she is a Russian
asset that means I've had a Russian
asset in my home and then you know by
proxy if you know how this stuff works I
might be a Russian proxy I might be a
Russian asset who the hell knows
so let's first get the exact quote from
Hillary Clinton because there seems to
be a lot of confusion around this
Hillary was on a podcast you've heard of
those podcasts everyone's got them and
here's exactly what Hillary said I'm not
making any predictions but I think
they've got their eye on somebody who is
currently in the Democratic primary and
are grooming her to be the third-party
candidate now of course she's talking
about the Russians there she does say
grooming her so we have some male
candidates some female candidates and we
really all know everyone knows even
though she did not say Tulsi by name
that she is talking about Tulsi how do
we know this well this is sort of an
idea that has been thrown around by the
Democratic establishment and by the
media constantly lately just last week
there was an absolutely horrific
ridiculous over-the-top but par for the
course article about Tulsi in the
newspaper formerly known as the New York
Times where they said she's backed by
Russian BOTS and the trolls and the all
right oh and that's scary Joe Rogan he's
gonna support her and she's been on
right wing YouTube shows who could they
be talking about it was an absolute
complete smear job and it's just that's
just standard stuff for the New York
Times at the moment so anyway Tulsi who
I've had on the show let me just talk
about her for just a moment first off I
found her to be a completely lovely
person she strikes me as the closest
thing that the mainstream Democrats have
to an old-school
liberal a JFK liberal an old-school
Democrat like daniel patrick moynihan
okay the type of democrat that maybe I
used to be I don't really think I am
anymore but somebody that has some of
the the basic ideas of classical
liberalism that the government isn't
supposed to do absolutely everything she
isn't a woke progressive she basically
is against identity politics if you
haven't seen my hour-and-a-half
interview with her I highly recommend it
she she isn't for late term abortions
she thinks third term abortions
abortions should be off the table that
was mainstream Democratic thought a
decade ago and now the Democrats
basically all the progressives are open
to abortion at any point she talks about
things like freedom and liberty and
actually paying for things these are all
things we talked about in our interview
she is more of an isolationist foreign
policy you would think that would be a
Democrat lefty idea but apparently now
that means you're a Russian asset now
the interesting thing here is some of
Hillary's defenders
well first off they're saying that no
she didn't really mean tulsi she was
just saying saying but also that it's
not just that she's an asset meaning
that she's working with or for the
Russians but but she might just be the
choice of the Russians because some of
her policy is aligned with what the
Russians might want that is an
incredibly dangerous slippery slope to
take that's like saying Rand Paul
because he's an isolationist he must be
a Russian asset too because scaling back
some of America's foreign influence
let's say in the Middle East might be
interesting to Russia so obviously R and
also Rand Paul from Kentucky the
Republican much like the Hawaiian
congresswoman from from Hawaii the
Hawaiian congresswoman from Hawaii that
they're that they're all Russian assets
it's all just silly nonsense and also
let's not forget because we seem to
forget things these days very easily we
just spent quite literally two and a
half to three years claiming that Russia
had hacked the election remember that
and that Trump stole the election and
worked with the Russians and all of
these things and guess what none of it
turned out to be true none of it
so Hillary's say
this making this baseless accusation
about Tulsi now unless she has some
evidence of it which we'd love to see
but as far as I know there is no
evidence of it her making this
accusation says far more about what's
going on with Hilary and the DNC
establishment than it does with Tulsi
and again I have some disagreements with
Tulsi and that's just fine but I do
think generally speaking if the
Democrats want to hold on to any of the
decent liberals and maybe they don't
right maybe they just want to move on
and and just go far-left progressive
woke machine and that's that's their
choice if they want but if they want to
hold on to any of the decent liberals
anymore then they might want to look at
somebody like Tulsi so in many ways
Hilary handed Tulsi a gift here but why
would she go after her well there's a
lot of reasons for it actually it's not
just that it's because Tulsi isn't
completely woke it's because Tulsi has
been talking about the DNC corruption
that everyone knows about she did it
right here watch this clip what's clear
is that this system lacks transparency
the whole process is lacking
transparency and that's the change and
that's the reform that I'm calling for
from the DNC and this so of course we
all know how corrupt the DNC has become
I mean they basically rigged the 2016
election and to talk took it stole it in
effect from Bernie and handed it over to
Hillary
we know that the former head of the DNC
Donna Brazile while working for CNN was
giving hillary debate questions so these
people are deeply deeply corrupt that
doesn't mean Republicans aren't deeply
corrupt in all of that but we're just
talking about the issue at hand here so
Hillary is pretty pissed at Tulsi
because Tulsi is calling out the
corruption Tulsi didn't take this whole
thing lying down though she sent out a
firestorm of tweets which I've got to
read to you she wrote great Thank You
Hillary Clinton you the queen of
warmongers embodiment of corruption and
personification of the rot that has SiC
in the Democratic Party
for so long have finally come out from
behind the curtain from the day I
announced my candidacy there has been a
concerted campaign to destroy my
reputation we wondered who was behind it
and why now we know it was you through
your proxies and powerful allies
in the corporate media and the war
machine afraid of the threat that I pose
it's now clear that this primary is
between you and me
don't cowardly hide behind your proxies
join the race directly so the last line
there I actually think is the most
interesting part so first off she's just
throwing pure pure fire there right like
she's just not taking it and I don't
think Hillary really realized who she
was going after by the way
tulsi gabbard who served twice in Iraq I
mean she's a member of the Armed
Services - to imply that she is somehow
a Russian asset or it's just it's just
it's the height of stupidity and
ridiculousness but this idea that you
know over the last couple weeks
Hillary's been getting into the media
again and doing more interviews and
showing up on the cable shows and
showing up on the view and the rest of
it it's like this really I think is
giving you a little hint as to where the
Democrats are at I think they're
starting to realize the Biden thing is
just breaking down it's just not working
it's it's in a way it's it's very sad I
think Biden at his best could have been
a more moderate Democrat he's been just
completely bamboozled by the woke thing
and he's literally saying that if you're
a man who identifies his woman you
should go out to go to a woman's prison
like it's what he said it's not what the
fact is it's what you feel you should do
I mean these are crazy positions he's
just lost in this party he's lost by the
progressives right it's just obvious and
now basically the Democrats are going
right we're gonna go full socialist
it'll either be Bernie or Elizabeth
Warren because the Biden thing isn't
working and Hillary I have a feeling if
you ask me right now I'm like I would
have said five percent a couple months
ago but I'm saying something like 25%
chance that Hillary gets back in this
thing and then there will be a an epic
political war all of this being said I
would say that this is actually good
because it's unearthing some of the
things that have to be unearthed
the Democrats have to decide which way
they want to go do you want to go
progressive woek do you want to buy ant
identity politics and collectivism and
and pin us all off on all of those
immutable characteristics I think you
guys know how I feel about that or do
you want to find some people
like Tulsi who actually seemed to love
this country who loved the founding
documents who serve in the Armed Forces
all of these things now you might have
some disagreements with her I think I
have some disagreements with her on farm
policy I think even the third term
abortion thing for me personally is a
bit much she's at least right now she's
for the impeachment inquiry on Trump I
think it's ridiculous she's there's a
series of other things I think she wants
more gun control than I was just a
couple things but it's very obvious and
Glenn Beck said this to me by the way
when I got back on the grid he said you
know it's very obvious that Tulsi
Gabbard even though I have some
differences with her loves this country
it's a little unclear to me what what
Hillary loves other than the control and
power she has over the DNC at the moment
so it's it's a real friggin mess but I
think it's a it's a necessary thing that
is happening right now and for those of
you that are Democrats that are still
Democrats it's up to you it's up to you
basically to decide which way you want
this party to go is it gonna go to
progressivism or is it gonna try to
remain with some decent semblance of
liberalism I kind of think the ship has
sailed and Tulsi is the last hope and I
and I also suspect that by the time the
DNC and the Hilary machine is done with
Tulsi and then done with yang that the
two of them are gonna go whoa maybe
we're Republicans because the
Republicans seem pretty open and decent
right no all right now or at least let's
say the the conservative side of things
or the more the more center-right part
of this anyway it's a really interesting
thing that's going on here
and the political game is afoot if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell